hello and welcome to today's webinar
closing the loop the circular economy
business and sustainability
we appreciate you joining us today
i'm anita wood
and i manage the stanford energy
innovation and emerging technologies
program also known as the eiet program
here at the stanford center for
professional development it is my
pleasure to introduce you to our guest
today julia novi
in this webinar julia will describe
steps businesses are taking to integrate
circular economy approaches into core
business strategies
and she will highlight key business
models of the circular economy and
discuss national and global trends
julia is professor of the practice and
executive director of the stanford's
change leadership for sustainability
program
and she co-teaches the xeit 110
strategies for sustainability course
which is in the eiet program
her research and her teaching focus on
business strategies leadership
approaches and cross-sector partnerships
that spur global development and align
systems with the goal of
intergenerational well-being
the change leadership program explores
the mindsets knowledge and tools leaders
need to accelerate the transition to
move more to a more sustainable and
resilient society
these include understanding complex
systems leading organizational change
and innovating in complex systems at
scale in order to shift sub-optimal
status quo orientations toward
sustainability
with over 20 years of experience leading
non-profit and philanthropic
philanthropic organizations julia
recognized for her innovative leadership
in designing scaling entrepreneurial uh
solutions to global challenges that
integrate economic social and
environmental objectives
in 2013 she founded resilience in action
which is dedicated to helping 21st
century leaders cultivate resilience in
their lives organizations and sectors
as executive director of the
wimbledon foundation julia was
responsible for guiding over 100 million
of investment in new technology
inventors and social enterprises in the
u.s and developing countries
julia also served as the director of
world wildlife fund specific marine
office where she collaborated with
colleagues at unilever and the world
wildlife fund to help develop and launch
the marine stewardship council
in 2010 julia was recognized as a
distinguished young global leader by the
world economic forum and served as a
topic leader for the clinton global
initiative on market-based solutions to
environmental challenges
julia is a fulbright and marshall
scholar and speaks french spanish
he swahili
and welcome julia
thank you anita um it's just really
wonderful to be here today with all of
you and um to have an opportunity to
share a glimpse of what's in the online
course anita mentioned that i co-created
with former dean pamela matson
of the school of earth energy and
environmental sciences and she and i are
the
primary co-instructors in that course
but we've got some great industry
experts who share their personal
experience and so circular economy is
one of the many
strategies and approaches we cover in
that course and i'm excited to kind of
delve into it a little bit more deeply
with you today
so in terms of the outline of what i'd
like to share this morning is first a
concept and conversation around
sustainability in business
it's really important to set the stage
in terms of what are we talking about
when we say sustainability and how does
an interdependent and complex view of
the world allow us to understand the
real promise of circularity so i'll do
that first context setting then talk
about the advantage of pursuing circular
economy and delve into five business
models that are particularly promising
in terms of applying and integrating
circular economy strategy into your
business and then finally if we have
time i'll tell a bit of a story about
what hp inc has been doing as a model
that you can consider as you think about
integrating circularity
so first of all
let's talk about sustainability um
often i think we hear sustainability and
we think of it as sort of a green term
or an environmental concept
and really sustainability is about
people it is about the well-being of all
of us
and not just a privileged few
and well-being over time how do we
secure the well-being of all people
across generations not just in this
current generation so that is
fundamentally about finding an economic
pathway a social pathway that is
provides for development that meets the
needs of the present as you see here on
the slide without compromising the
ability of future generations to meet
their own needs and this came from the
world commission on environment and
development back in 1987 when we first
defined what sustainable development
means as a global community
so
another way i want to think about
sustainability today is
in a very interdependent way i think we
you know in in business we often hear
about the three pillars economy society
environment we see them as sort of these
three separate pillars that we need to
think about or occasionally we will see
them as an overlapping venn diagram of
three circles economy society and
environment
this interdependent view of
sustainability is much more accurate in
terms of how the world actually works
our economy
is a wholly owned subsidiary of the
environment and not the other way around
as urban ecologist and philosopher jane
jacobs points out we do not have an
economy without a thriving environment
so to see
our economic and social
cultural strategies
as embedded in the environment is
absolutely fundamental in terms of
understanding how can we advance um
well-being in the world and that's where
circularity comes from we have to base
our understanding of
what we need to do in business on the
reality of how the world works and the
world works in terms of complex
interdependent systems where the economy
society and environment are all highly
interconnected and interdependent on one
another
so let me just go into a little bit of a
conversation around complicated versus
complex because as i just said we are
living in a complex dynamic world with
feedbacks and trade-offs between what we
do and how that affects the natural
environment and how the natural
environment affects us and so
understanding as business leaders the
difference between complicated contexts
and complex is highly important because
we are living in a complex world our
operating environment in business is
complex so let's look at differentiating
the two so we can really understand
complex and then make decisions about
how do we work effectively in a complex
world so first off complicated okay what
characterizes a complicated context
first of all it's a context that
contains intricately contain
combined or involved parts
one would say the opposite of
complicated is simple
you've got a definable problem in a
complicated context usually existing
know-how is adequate
and you know sometimes it requires
expert knowledge but still it's existing
knowledge and that you're in a
relatively stable context and the
outcome is predictable
when you shift to thinking about complex
challenges or the nature of our complex
operating environment you see that we
have parts that are so interconnected as
to make the whole perplexing and when
you think about some of the social
environmental interactions i just
mentioned right between society and the
environment
the opposite of complex is really
important is independent because by
definition complexity is about
relationships it's about all of these
complex relationships these
interdependencies that exist in our
world we've seen it of course with coven
really coming home you know how
interdependent we are so the opposite of
complex is independent um
in complex context many parts of a
problem are not definable
there is therefore a need for constant
adaptation improvisation experimentation
learning to keep figuring out ways that
work in this complex dynamic world
and in complex contexts were
usually in an unstable situation
unstable context where the outcomes are
not entirely predictable
and so that you know just getting our
heads around complexity and
interdependence is central to
understanding then business strategies
that will actually work over the long
term and allow us to secure
intergenerational well-being which is
how i defined sustainability a minute
ago
a simple way to think about it maybe is
a ferrari in a rainforest a ferrari
falls in the realm of complicated you
know you could take it all apart very
complicated but all those parts with an
expert mechanic and the right blueprint
you could put right back together the
whole is the sum of the parts take a
tropical rainforest much more dynamic
complex with all sorts of relationships
between
the various animals and the you know
systems of that forest you do something
different like reroute a water source or
let a species go extinct you don't
actually know
how it's gonna affect the system how to
bring it back to good function
so
one way to think about
this in kind of business terms is vuca
world maybe many of you have heard this
concept it actually came from the us
army war college after the end of the
cold war to describe the kind of new
geopolitical context that we were facing
where things weren't so simple anymore
it wasn't just the us and russia anymore
us and ussr anymore it was a much more
complex geopolitical environment and now
since the quarter of early 2000s
business has been using that as a way to
describe the volatile uncertain complex
and ambiguous operating environment we
need to figure out how to work in
so what is business doing about this
recognition that we are living in a
complex world where there are all sorts
of non-linearities and feedbacks and
time delays in terms of us taking action
and seeing how that plays out in the
natural world and
getting feedbacks well first of all
business is taking a much more systems
perspective
this reality this complex reality
requires business to recognize that it
is part of a much larger dynamic system
both affecting that system and being
affected by it and so paul pullman
former ceo of unilever talks about how
business needs to take more of a systems
approach to their operations seeing
companies as part of an interconnected
web
linking multiple players
and you know taking this systems
perspective
once we shift our minds to doing that a
couple of things naturally follow first
it becomes very clear that we have
greater responsibility than we thought
because all of a sudden we broaden our
view and we see gosh you know you look
out to the supply chain to all the
people we're engaged with in our
business we have responsibility beyond
our core company and that leads us to
see these individuals and partners and
say okay how do we engage
more fully the various stakeholders this
much broader perspective on stakeholders
who are involved in our work
second
it calls us to integrate sustainability
how can we
actually work in this complex system and
thrive ourselves as well as deliver good
outcomes in the world without
integrating sustainability this is
essential for risk mitigation so we can
you know really continue
it's also
critical for resilience building
resilience and even more so for value
creation we can't create long-term value
without integrating sustainability into
core strategy
so with that kind of foundation of
thinking about interdependence
complexity and sustainability let's look
at why the circular economy
aligns with this more systemic view
of reality
and the business operating environment
one premise is that if we can think
about gosh
we have
a system and we can capture
use
pass around energy as much as possible
before it leaves the system
we have a lot more to work with if we
kind of pull energy in and let it
disperse quickly we have a lot less to
work with and if you look at kind of how
we've been doing business for a very
long time it is much more the latter
we've had a very linear economy where we
are sort of on the take make waste
approach to producing goods we take
natural resources from the earth we make
goods and serve goods and products and
we dispose of them often before the end
of their natural life cycle
this linear
system
has significant limits on on a finite
planet of course and so
how do we kind of think about shifting
from the take make waste model
to one of circularity and that's what
this talk is really delving into
and it leans on what we already know
from natural systems i mean natural
systems have had 3.8 billion years to
evolve in a way that makes sense
in this complex interdependent world
that we're living in if you look at the
amazon rainforest food web you see that
every species involved
is
connected
and also providing service and allowing
there to be actually no waste in that
system
all waste in natural systems is actually
broken down and captured
um reused as nutrients for other
organisms so if you think about say
animal waste from monkeys and tipiers in
this forest or leaf litter that falls to
the ground it's broken down by the
bacteria and fungi you see there in the
bottom of the picture
and those transform these wastes into
nutrients that create healthy soils and
support the growth of trees and animals
so
what can we learn from this system and
what can we reflect on in terms of how
we've done things in the past this is
just a bit of a glimpse of how we've
done things in the past this is
showing that we have followed this kind
of linear model to
use resources in order to generate
economic development
that worked with a relatively small
global population
but now we have to ask ourselves a new
question how can we help more people
experience well-being
not just get out of poverty but actually
thrive in a resource-constrained world
so there are 2.5 billion people who will
join the middle class by 2030. that's
you know less than 10 years from now
and we can't do it following this model
shown in this graph with this linear
high resource consumption to drive
economic development projections are
that we would actually need three planet
earths to do that
okay so we
we've got an indication there that we
can't continue in this path
another indication is just sort of an
economic read this is a study by
accenture global consulting firm
that basically shows that markets are
finally reflecting the reality of our
resource constrained world before 2000
you can see there on the graph
the commodity price index fell with gdp
growth
we seem to have figured out we thought
you know a way to keep growing with
cheaper and cheaper commodities
what we don't see in that graph is that
this was of course because we were not
paying the true cost of our economic
development and growth the cost of our
wasteful practices were externalized so
through big subsidies
that didn't show the true cost but
nonetheless even with this
externalization of cost by 2000 there
was a fundamental shift in which
commodity prices started
going up by 1.5 percent on average for
every percentage of growth in gdp
and again this was without factoring in
externalities
so fundamentally now if we kind of delve
into circular economy circular economy
is about
finding ways to decouple this economic
development that we need um from the use
of scarce resources
and it requires disruptive technology
disruptive business models based on very
different principles from our linear
system and that's why i talked at the
beginning about moving to a mindset of
understanding complexity and
interdependence because once we really
make that shift and see the world
through much more of a relationship lens
we can understand
why we need to make these fundamental
disruptive shifts in technology and
business so we need them to focus on
longevity you can see in this list
renewability
reuse
repair
upgrade think about the amazon forest as
you think about these words and how it
functions right refurbishment
capacity sharing
and dematerialization
so those are some of the fundamental
principles
of circular economy
and then you know
holding those principles is a culture is
a mindset it's a set of norms and so far
we've had sort of a mindset that we can
continue to use resources and throw them
away and what we're starting to
recognize is kind of there is no away
right we are living on one planet earth
wherever we throw things that away is
here and so we're bumping up against
that reality europe and china are much
further ahead than the united states in
circular economy approaches in part
because they've bumped up against that
reality faster because they have less
land compared to the number of people
but um the cultural paradigm shift we
need to make in terms of mindset is
as we think about interdependence and
relationships and complexity we start
seeing that gosh maybe we can move from
ownership and consumption mindsets
to just accessibility if we can access
the things we need do we actually need
to own them or consume them directly
from products and production to services
and sharing
as long as we get the service the
service of lighting do we actually need
to produce
um and own the product of light um
designing for obsolescence has been our
way so that companies can make more by
selling more
designing for longer life how do we
create business models that generate
revenue and profit by designing for
longer life
moving from waste a vision of there's
just waste we got to get rid of it to
gosh waste is actually resources not yet
put to use how can we see waste
differently
and finally from less bad to more good i
think you know a lot of our orientation
has been in the business world to gosh
okay we've got to get on the
sustainability um train
maybe we can just minimize our you know
environmental footprint
reduce waste reduce energy use all of
that's very important and we need to say
how are we as critical players in the
economy to generate this goal to advance
this goal of intergenerational
well-being so not just to do less harm
but to actually be critical players
in moving us towards a sustainable
society
so let's look for a minute at waste
because waste is so central um and sort
of a keystone piece of understanding
circularity this is um from studies done
by accenture
looking at sort of taking a four
dimensional view on waste in order to
see the real potential of circular
economy
comes from the book waste to wealth that
was published a few years ago and
explains that you know by 2030 the
linear growth model's inability to deal
with growing demand for resources will
result in a gap of 8 billion tons
between supply of and demand for
constrained natural resources so this
figure nearly equals the total resource
use in 2014. so if you think about all
the resources we use back in 2014 in
this entire country the gap between the
demand and supply
of 8 billion tons for natural resources
in just eight years um that's the
estimate
so um
the most likely scenario that they
modeled in the study translates to 4.5
trillion dollars of lost growth in just
eight years
ballooning to almost six times that or
yeah just under six times that to 25
trillion in just 20 more years after
that so um we've got to understand waste
and see what we can do about it as we
move towards circularity so first
if you look at the top right quadrant
there we have wasted resources in our
sourcing or sorry the top left quadrant
wasted resources in our sourcing and
manufacturing that could be tackled by
introducing better practices renewable
energy bio-based and green chemicals
and naturally based materials
so um
if you think about for instance
farming only 40 of irrigation water
actually reaches the plants it was
intended for
so we're very wasteful in terms of our
sourcing and also manufacturing
second in the right quadrant top
we have wasted capacity so many products
are not fully utilized think about the
automobile cars are parked 92 percent of
the time
and offices are used only 35 to 40
percent of the time that's probably less
now with coven
and that's only during working hours so
35 to 40 of the time during working
hours
bottom right quadrant um third we have
wasted life cycles we end up land
filling back to that linear model we
landfill products when we could maintain
repair or remanufacture them
and fourth in that bottom left quadrant
we have wasted embedded values if we
harvested components from products and
increased recycling and energy recovery
we could capture the resources in many
products that are often lost
so understanding waste
goes back to that amazon rainforest
analogy of
redefining waste as resources not yet
put to use how do we see waste very
differently see opportunities
okay so let's just take a step back and
look at the global scope
of the circular economy
accenture in the
wealth book i mentioned estimates it to
be worth 4.5 trillion by 2030
um creating an unassailable competitive
advantage for firms the european
commission in 2016
um said that circular activities
generated almost 147 billion euros in
value added
ing
the dutch multinational banking and
financial services firm
says the u.s focus on sustainability is
dramatically intensifying that twice as
many firms
between between years of 2018 and 2019
so just in one year are embedding
sustainability into strategic decision
making and circularity is a big part of
that
so how does circularity kind of increase
competitiveness
three main factors have been highlighted
by the analyses that have been done of
businesses pursuing circularity first
in the area of growth and cons customers
capturing a multi-billion dollar
opportunity from financing the circular
economy is possible if you consider
airbnb they created a 35 billion dollar
business without using any energy metal
or other resources to build a single
house
increasing competitiveness and
profitability uh through profitability
um some companies are increasing gross
profit by 50
while reducing material use by 90
percent
all by recovering and remanufacturing
used components
and then sustainability and trust
companies are closing the loop on
materials and products to create supply
chain security
and enhance consumer relations because
if you're
closing the loop and say leasing instead
of
selling you stay in touch with your
consumers you get more information from
them you also control that product so
you can recycle and reuse a lot of the
original products you have much more
supply chain security and we'll look in
a moment at how michelin has done that
by and turning some of its entire
company into a business that leases
rather than sells tires
okay so let's now that we've kind of
understood the global context as
interdependent
complex dynamic recognize that a linear
model doesn't work in in the world of
interdependence because it fundamentally
discounts the reality of total
connection and and systems
thinking
and so circularity is an approach a
holistic integrated approach that makes
much more sense in a world of
interdependence
let's look now more deeply at five
business models that companies are using
that have yielded the greatest impact
from a circular economy
perspective so um when accenture did its
study of over 120 companies these five
circular business models and have
emerged as the most significant
they include circular supply chain
recovery and recycling
product life extension
sharing platform
and product as service
so let's just look at an example or two
of each one
so in terms of circular supply chain
when a company needs resources that are
scarce or environmentally destructive it
can either pay more or find alternatives
and the circular economy
circular supply chain business model
introduces fully renewable recyclable or
biodegradable materials
as the core for the manufacturing
process
and of course then by nature these can
be used in consecutive life cycles to
continue to reduce costs increase
predictability and control and of course
have no environmental negative impact
ecobative design is just a fascinating
company i actually had a really
special connection to this company gosh
20
years ago when i was executive director
of the levels foundation we gave one of
our many university grants um ten
thousand dollars to these two guys at
rensselaer polytechnic when they came up
with this idea of using mycelium which
is a natural fungi it's the kind of the
threads that
pull that mushrooms can grow from
and they found a way to grow this and
create products from it that would
replace styrofoam
other plastics
leather
allowing us to provide alternatives to
those foam packaging peanuts the
styrofoam packaging peanuts other
synthetic insulation products that are
really um toxic
and even furniture and other
construction materials that um
can be much more sustainable and
biodegradable so they have grown so much
since then they're now a multi-million
dollar company
with many series of rounds of investment
and have scaled up to a very diverse
product line um the company anticipates
the prices to fall
quite soon to 10 to 30 percent below
traditional alternatives so they're
actually able to come in now with this
investment in their growth to a lower
cost and um in terms of
you know competing for scarce land
obviously as we're trying to feed 10
billion people by 2050 we've got to
think about land use
this fungi these mycelium can be built
in a lab so they aren't competing for
land availability with food producers
a second business model to consider is
recovery and recycling so in the
recovery and recycling business model
everything previously considered waste
is revived for other uses effectively
eliminating not only waste but the
concept of waste you know it's just a
material that we need to figure out how
we can use
so companies either recover end-of-life
products
to recapture and reuse valuable material
energy and components or they reclaim
waste and buy products from a production
process
so this business model requires a
two-way supply chain
so you're moving products to consumers
and customers and bringing end-of-life
goods back
different industries can share
by-product resources so you can have
clustering where one company like this
example of novelis and ford i'll talk
about in a second one company can direct
sell to other industries that need or
want your unneeded or unwanted outputs
of your production process so for
example ford created an innovative
supply chain that allows ford to reuse
most of the 40
of the aluminum scrap
that is produced in the production of
its aluminum f-150s
ford made an investment installed 60
million worth of pneumatic scrap
handling equipment separates aluminum
alloy scraps after a vehicle is
manufactured and then the shredded scrap
scrap is shipped to a novelis plant
where novelis then processes it back
into aluminum sheets and coils
and ford purchases it from novelis to
then use on new vehicles
interface is another fascinating example
this is a huge carpet manufacturer a
real leader um
real leader in advancing sustainability
from a corporate
strategy perspective
they use nylon first of all from
discarded fishing nets that are a huge
issue in the ocean i you may have heard
from my bio used to work in marine
conservation for world wildlife fund and
discarded fishing gear is a huge problem
in the ocean
killing a lot of marine life but also
leading to plastic
increased plastic in the ocean so they
use nylon from discarded fishing nets to
make carpet and they combine
that material with recycled pvb
from building glass and car windscreens
pvb is like an adhesive that helps the
glass stay together but be flexible and
have optical clarity
so
all those windscreens used to just
completely go to the landfill they now
use pvb from these windscreens to use to
replace latex
relatively toxic substance in carpet
tiles and through this they've managed
to reduce their carbon footprint by 80
percent
um
if you think about it they're one
billion cars in the world annually on
average five to six percent have a
replacement window it's a lot and pbb
had not ever had a second life until
interface found this opportunity
okay the third model to talk about
product life extension through
remanufacturing i mentioned michelin so
they have transitioned from a product to
a service oriented business model you
remember when i talked about some of
those cultural shifts earlier this idea
of moving how do we move from sort of
product thinking to service thinking
from ownership to accessibility so by
leasing rather than selling tires the
company stays engaged with its customers
gathering feedback from them to inform
product innovation so when they get a
tire back they can look at the tire see
how it's worn talk to the customer see
what worked or didn't work about the
tire and that allows them to spur
innovation that immediate feedback by
staying connected to consumers and being
able to look at the actual product after
it's been used
also by controlling its product good
tires can be recovered and released
so
they're still good when they come back
from the first lease they can get leased
again
at the end if they are kind of end of
life cycle tires
michelin all of a sudden now controls
the the core content of its product the
rubber in those tires and they can be
recycled into playground surfaces or
converted into fuel
so the company has moved on this quite
quickly in
in the eu in particular but also brazil
and has 97
recycling rates in those two locations
caterpillar um
has done something quite similar um
but for their
product they have a global network of
remanufacturing facilities and they take
back millions of end-of-life units for
remanufacturing so the company
remanufactures hundreds of millions of
pounds of material each year
um this remanufacturing process is much
less energy intensive than producing new
materials 85 to 95 percent less than new
production and so it both reduces waste
and also the need for virgin resources
okay so finally
sharing platform is our fifth business
model to consider
in developed economies industrialized
economies up to eighty percent of things
stored in the home
are used only once a month
so again this huge idling capacity when
we looked at that four dimensional view
of waste you can see
you know a lot of inefficiencies in
terms of our use of all these products
that we have the sharing platform
business model provides a platform to
connect product owners with individuals
or organizations that would like to use
them
boosting the productivity of products
that may sit idle by allowing co-access
or co-ownership
so
the sharing economy is not new as you
probably know i mean think of libraries
that we've had for so long and bartering
in traditional societies
or just simple you know neighborhood
sharing of tool sheds that we've had in
many places around the world farming
communities
um but at the scale it's operating it's
emerged from a context of recognizing
our limited resources
of having the density of urbanization
where you've got large groups of people
together who need common things
um
and then digital platforms are
breakthroughs in terms of the internet
and the digital platforms that exist
that enable matchmaking between people
with things to share and those who want
to use them
and then our natural drive to connect
you know the kind of malaise of urban
life where we'd actually like to be more
connected like we used to be in more
traditional communities
a lot of the proponents of the sharing
economy highlight actually the new
relationships that develop with
neighbors and other people in community
as a result of the sharing connections
are one of the most valuable outcomes of
sharing economy
so um
when we look back also those culture
trends this ties very much into access
over ownership that idea of making that
shift from from ownership to access
um the sharing economy is as many of you
are aware it has evolved over you know
many years um at scale at the scale
we're seeing it now so starting first
with kind of the craigslist of the world
classified advertisements to the rentals
of homes through airbnb
to then taskrabbit a marketplace for
small jobs and then of course
to passengers um connecting with drivers
such as through lyft and uber and then a
marketplace like udemy for teaching and
learning and so many more
than that
what we're starting to see is that
sharing platform model which is unlike
the other models that was very much
consumer to consumer or peer-to-peer
individual to individual rather than
business to business um
that still is the dominant feature of
the sharing economy and what's really
important as a complement to these other
models which are much more business to
business
and as the
customer to customer or peer-to-peer
sharing platforms mature the model is
actually becoming more visible in
business to business as well so we're
starting to see it kind of enter that
scale as well especially for expensive
assets with low utilization rates so
storefront is one sharing economy
company that is using
short-term retail space rentals for
pop-up retail locations
so that's one manifestation at the b2b
level and then flow 2 started in
scandinavia enables sharing of massive
construction technologies such as earth
diggers tractors excavators
allowing companies and institutions to
access not just the technology but the
services and skills
of personnel as well
so all of this is very much an evolution
and businesses you know are driving the
innovation of these models as they
experiment and make change
so let's sum up just briefly the key
points
on circular economy and then we'll go
briefly into a story about hewlett
packard so
first of all
circular economy like the amazon
rainforest it closes the loop in
production using renewable resources and
integrating outputs and byproducts into
production it creates a closed loop
environment where all waste is are just
resources not yet put to use and it's a
way of figuring out how to first of all
not generate toxic waste by changing the
materials through the circular um supply
chain model and then once we've got
materials out in circulation how do we
keep them in circulation for as long as
possible like that first quote i
mentioned uh when we shifted to talk
about circular economy how do we take
energy into the system you look at the
rain forest right taking sun and water
and all of that energy into the system
and keeping it in circulation for as
long as possible how do we design our
economy
so that we can do that second as i
mentioned it's about values and culture
it's a new value system based on an
understanding of complexity and
interdependence that emphasizes access
long-term
thinking sharing and decoupling the
critical decoupling of development are
creating our well-being and the
well-being of the nearly 10 billion
people we're expecting by 2050
decoupling that from the use of scarce
resources because we know we can't
follow that traditional linear model i
showed and actually achieve this goal of
intergenerational well-being
i talked about the enormous financial
potential
based on the studies of accenture ing
studies from the eu and the
manifestation that engagement in
circular economy is growing globally
we talked a little bit about the
competitive advantage it offers for
business in the areas of growth customer
relations and profitability
and described those five circular
business models
so let's um talk briefly about a story
of hp inc this is
maybe something you can consider as you
think about gosh how might we actually
take a step if we haven't already in
circular economy if we've taken a few
steps what might be the next steps we
could take
hp inc
began with their company vision
their vision is to reinvent everything
we do
every day
their product relationship with
customers
how they bring products to marketplace
so they're really kind of
looking at this way of like how can we
keep improving ourselves and society
through reinvention questioning how we
do things being open to doing things
differently this adapt orientation is so
essential you know once you connect with
the reality of an interdependent world
and see that you then need to say okay
gosh how do we need to adapt this way of
thinking that we've had before these
linear ways of operating these
ways of sort of generating waste over
here so we can have profitability over
there don't make sense when you take a
systems perspective on the world and you
see everything as interconnected
and so you know dave packard early on
said the betterment of our society is
not a job to be left to a few it is a
responsibility to be shared by all so um
from this kind of core part of their
vision and i think for each you know of
us in our organizations and companies we
got to go back to that core purpose and
vision and say okay
that's where we start and then what
makes sense to take from there in terms
of circularity sustainability strategy
and so their sustainability impact
strategy kind of formulated around this
concept of planet
people and community not unlike that
nested
three circles i shared at the beginning
with economy society and environment
they identified
a major problem that they are part of
plastic waste
just incredible to look at this 1955
life magazine article that was promoting
this throwaway culture you know back to
culture and how powerful culture is
we really promoted this how wonderful
plastics were because they allowed mary
jane here
and her family to have a dinner party
and she would only have sort of 30
minutes of cleanup to do instead of
hours and hours because everything could
be thrown away it was called throwaway
living and so you know now hp looks at
it says gosh we've promoted the wide use
of plastics in the 50s and we now have
11 million metric tons of plastic
entering the ocean each year
and if you take a systems perspective we
are part of that reality
um and so how do we
look at this and say not just how do we
do less bad but how can we actually be
contributing to more good
so they first evaluated areas of their
business with the greatest carbon
footprint and confirmed that they could
make a significant material impact by
integrating plastic recycling in their
supply chain so the supply chain piece
of their business had a little less than
the products in solution in terms of
carbon footprint but it was one they
could get their hands around more
because it was the materials they were
using for manufacturing their products
their products and solutions that part
of the supply chain was really looking
at
the carbon footprint generated by
consumers customers like you and me
using their products using their
printers and the energy we were
consuming using that which is a little
bit more difficult for them to
impact so they said okay let's dig in to
a hugely material part of our work part
of our company business the supply chain
and say what can we
actually do
to minimize waste and maybe even help
clean up some of the world's oceans
so
they first said
gosh
do we have any experience in our company
in doing any of this have we innovated
in this area at all and can we learn
from it and also use that to inform the
feasibility of this idea and what the
goal should be
well sure enough
they had for many years uh innovated in
the area of plastics recycling quite
recently they had created the tango
printer shown there on the left
which is made from 30 recycled plastic
including old printers
so they knew that was possible they'd
also been using
recycled plastics and making print
cartridges for quite a number of years
so with that perspective they set an
ambitious goal to use 30 percent
of post-consumer recycled content
across its
recycled plastic content across their
personal systems and print portfolio
they're currently at seven percent their
vision is 100 long term and their goal
mid-range goal is to reach 30 percent
so they then said okay gosh we've you
know done this for for a while with our
print cartridges
we um
after customers buy
ink and use it they return their empty
cartridges to hp
we sort and shred the materials we add
bottles and hangers to that and then we
um make original cartridges with that
recycled plastic
and they said gosh how do we get those
million bottles of plastic per day um
maybe we can think about a new way of
sourcing those
and they looked at haiti
and saw a huge opportunity
in haiti
this is a canal in haiti when it rains
this canal floods and takes
plastics out to the ocean
lots of it washes up back to shore
and um
the more hp learned about i actually
have to pause i'm i'm feeling really
really ill for a second here i'm sorry i
i need to pause
that that's okay julia um go ahead and
um take a moment there um if you want to
adjust if you have a chair close by
yeah
yeah there we go um
no problem
and um
go ahead and take a break
and i want to thank everybody for coming
um we do have a number of questions um
that were submitted
and um for things to think about um i
i'd like to take you through perhaps uh
the next slide
and um
show how the impact um
uh hp has made
um with bringing a community and finding
opportunity
um and so you can see
folks here
working to
with hp
to
take the
bottled products and plastics out of the
environment creating a job opportunity
and uh in places where perhaps there
wasn't one
and
we i think we've all seen the pictures
of uh all the plastic um in in our
oceans and i know at least for me it
does
make me sad on certain days
um and i'm glad to know that there are
people that are addressing
the issue
um you can see that
utilizing over 25 million bottles of
ocean-bound plastic
which is phenomenal
and then bring in the local community
and the
young
to learn about
what's going on and providing them with
the technology
to
learn about
what what they can do and how they can
be a part of this
process
not only to
improve business their life community
but also to save the earth
and you can see here some folks that
participated in the program
and um
uh
and i know julia would have more to talk
about for this one
um
and um but it's great showing how people
came together
um working with hp
to pull this off there you are
oh can't can't hear you so you might
have to switch to your
computer audio can you hear me now
yeah yeah yeah i'm so sorry oh my gosh
i've been struggling a bit with some
health issues and i just felt like i was
like getting super hot and might like
i don't know so i'm so sorry but anita
thanks for i'm just gonna sit i think
for the rest but i really appreciate you
finishing up i mean i'll just say
this opportunity in haiti was one where
they took a very holistic systems
perspective on the challenge so that you
know this whole idea of the people
planet and um
community that they had set as their
original strategy based on their core
vision was really manifest in what they
were able to do in haiti um so like from
a materials perspective from a planet
perspective they said gosh you know we
can actually address some of the ocean
plastic pollution issue by using
recycled instead of virgin materials and
by using plastic bound for the oceans
rather than from an already established
kind of global plastics market so they
could actually be part of the oceans
related issue and then from a people
perspective in haiti there's an 80
percent unemployment rate um so there's
a need to like
solve for jobs
living wages um
huge opportunity there to say okay gosh
how can we actually ensure that waste
pickers and people who are involved in
this plastics recycling supply chain can
earn a fair wage um and and get out of
basically unemployment or living on a
far below kind of living wage and then
from a community standpoint they engage
you know as anita pointed out in that
last slide which i'll get to um
they supported education
they worked with a local ngo to improve
health and education particularly for
the children of of of workers so
you know if you look at here they
basically found
a local partner and this is back to the
kind of relationship lens and looking
out and feeling greater responsibility
in your supply chain they looked outward
and said okay how
um
how might we engage a local partner in
this and they found this recycler but it
needed that that group needed a lot of
capacity building actually to meet hp
standards so they invested in the
capacity building of this local recycler
so
they worked with them on cleanliness
standards so the materials could
actually be clean enough to be used by
hp
so they had to teach them about
eliminating contamination and how to
remove labels and caps just basic
capacity building and then they worked
with the recycler on supply chain code
of conduct so they improved the standard
the social standards in this company
improving the treatment of workers their
ergonomics standing there at that
sorting machine on
comfortable blocks instead of cement
floor
creating better working conditions
better safety standards
and then require them to offer a living
wage
several times higher than the haitian
minimum wage
they also then invested in helping this
recycler with their business operation
so they helped remove cost and
inefficiency from their process they
were compressing and then shredding the
bottles but compressing wasn't necessary
so they helped them kind of innovate to
improve profitability as well so um
those pictures that you that anita
shared you know here's you know the
ocean plastics bound
now used in printers also these are the
the children of waste pickers who are
now in school accessing technology using
a printer made from ocean bound plastic
in haiti and again just this emphasis of
as anita mentioned the the whole supply
chain and really thinking about
how does everyone fit together you've
got hp inc kind of
central headquarters represented by
ellen jakowski on the left
driving this whole process thinking
holistically about it tying it to hp
inc's vision and then you've got
richardson from haiti the the country
manager for first mile which is you know
he's kind of over there towards the
right
and he is the one involved with kind of
being hp's country manager working on
environment health and safety for the
collectors
and then work the organization called
work is providing the educational and
medical access pictured there on the far
right
and then ed the ceo of the recycling
company how he was able to evolve things
to really provide better work greater
business efficiency for himself and
profitability but living wages for the
people working for him so um and then
just the continued innovation so hp this
slide talks about this two million
dollar washing line investment so they
leverage funds to invest in this washing
line um it's up and running this year or
i guess maybe prior a couple years ago
and the idea was to significantly
increase quality and production quantity
um in haiti adding another thousand
income opportunities for people so jobs
um current before this washing station
dirty flakes were sent to south carolina
to get washed
um
that was a pretty inefficient process
you know to ship all of that out and and
do that part of the process there so now
they're bringing that capacity into
haiti for a comparable cost but
obviously a carbon reduction in terms of
the extra transport and also keeping
value in haiti allowing them to kind of
pursue their people planet um objectives
so i'll stop there and answer questions
and thank you all for for being patient
i i'm feeling much better now
so happy to answer some questions
thank you very much and we do have a
number of questions let's uh see what we
can uh do here
and i'm going to go ahead and
take us to the last
right there
um let's see here
what
up you know on people's mind and i'm not
sure how comfortable you are to answer
this question
um we had a couple questions come in
regarding the situation in ukraine
and
one key one is how could
uh ukrainians people around the world
come together to transform after the war
transform ukraine
to follow these approaches and
methodologies
you have
ideas suggestions
how can
organizations nonprofits or profit
um rebuild
um
[Music]
sustainability in mind i three uh i
threw your heart balls sorry
no i mean this is exactly the nature of
i mean i love that question because that
is exactly the mindset that we actually
need to shift to which is
looking at the whole world
this complex system and saying we've got
to bring these kind of approaches these
approaches that recognize
interdependence that recognize
complexity
and that are actually durable long-term
ways of doing things and see how we can
apply them so i think it's the most
perfect question
i mean gosh a few thoughts one is i love
this quote about systems change which is
that in order to change a system you
need to change the relationships of the
actors in the system so what would it
look like to look at ukraine and say you
know
who are the core stakeholders for
rebuilding that country you know all of
them and what are their current
relationships how could those
relationships be different
um
in such a way as to create
a sustainable strong society so i would
say you know beyond economy what are the
the cultural and social aspects that
would help and then the other thing i
think with systems change that we
sometimes forget about it is all about
relationships and but it's not just
changing the existing relationships it
is that and it's often introducing new
relationships so maybe are there actors
that
aren't yet engaged that need to be those
relationships that need to be formed or
are there um
new kinds of enterprises that need to to
emerge so
um i think you know to be concrete in
terms of circular economy i would say
you know first we've got to look at
policies are there policies that um
incentivize waste are there policies
that incentivize reuse of materials
um or how what are the taxing systems
like governments can tax
labor or they could tax resource use you
know maybe we shouldn't be taxing labor
we value human contribution
but we tax resource use so you know
that's one piece you could look at the
policies and then you could look at you
know specific do a sector analysis you
know what are the biggest sources of the
economy
um
most important parts of the economy in
the ukraine and look at them one by one
just like accenture did from a material
standpoint and say
where is the greatest opportunity for
circularity in these core business
sectors and learn from other models
around the world in similar sectors and
what they've done and see how those
could be applied in ukraine but i
started my answer with a broader point
because i do think that's the most
fundamental is a cultural shift and and
often in crisis we're more poised to
make cultural shifts so there may be an
opportunity gosh i'm the ukrainians i've
been on a feed as part of my young
global leader network with our ukrainian
partners um young global leaders they
are giving us just these fees on what's
going on in the war and what they're
thinking about and i can say they are
so determined and so um committed it's
quite extraordinary so i think
the potential for like being radical and
saying let's just shift the whole
economy to circularity and let's do this
in one fell swoop i mean i think there's
a good moment in crisis for that kind of
radical change so i mean exciting
exciting opportunity and great question
hope that helps some
that's great i i appreciate the
you know i hadn't really thought about
the
taxing you know
labor versus
um
uh products and and different policies
that can really influence um
change so that that that was great um
yeah i think we have time for maybe one
more question
um and this is about the balance between
capitalism
and
sustainability in the circular economy
and finding
um there were two questions that were
related so this one with capitalism and
sustainability
um and uh the product life cycle if we
we create develop products that have a
longer life cycle people purchase less
um and
we may not be polluting more
but
then how do companies regain that
profitability it's capitalism
okay i'm not sure i fully can you give
me the high
high level on that question i'm not sure
it's probably got
um if uh
corporations organizations or
corporations for-profit corporations are
developing products that have a longer
lifespan
and
they don't charge more because uh the
the product is is the same price um they
won't be selling more product right
people won't be buying more right now we
have the throwaway economy i will buy
you know 500 plates yeah okay
yeah
well i think embedded in that question
is
kind of stick staying with the mindset
of
selling products is the path for income
so i think what circularity and kind of
how we need to think is is how
do we reinvent so that that isn't
necessarily the path for income it's not
just selling products it's selling a
service
and how do you value that service and
access to that service how do you
innovate in new areas where there is
consumer demand and do it in a way that
is durable and i think you know i do
recommend the book waste to wealth peter
lacy is one of the main lead authors
lacy
and it really goes into what this looks
like economically and what the shift is
but it does require you know it's not
about and and also i would say you don't
have to necessarily assume that you
can't sell that product for more i mean
if there is longevity
you know pricing you shouldn't assume
that the pricing would stay the same um
so that's one piece but the other piece
is to recognize if you're shifting from
product to service it's just a kind of a
whole different business model where
profit coming in is is generated in a
very different way
great um i think we'll do
one more quick question do you know how
long it took hp to make that transition
to implement
that circular economy
approach
well it built on a lot so for 15 years
maybe it's now 18 or so they've been
working on those print cartridges so all
of us can go online and find out the
place nearest us where we can recycle
our little hp print cartridges they've
been doing that for about 15 to 20 years
and invested a lot i remember talking to
ellen jakowski the head of
sustainability at hp inc about
how much they invested in like these
machines to sort and you know
deconstruct and clean and um
to figure out actually practically how
to do that and to build them the
technology to
remanufacture so it did take investment
but they they learned a great deal
through it and then they've kind of
innovated on that so for example as i
showed in that slide
they used to source a million plastic
bottles a day and that was from a global
plastics market where you know just you
could buy it off the market these use
plastic bottles
then when they got into the haiti
project they said well actually we can
not just source from a from a market
other people can take that we'll take
the higher risk
more challenging piece which is getting
that plastic off the ground before it
goes into the ocean
so we can stop that problem in a really
important country and use it as an
opportunity to also support development
and so the haiti project has been
probably the last
i don't know for sure we we need to look
it up but i think probably about this
last seven to seven years or so
um
right great um with that we've we've hit
time um i want to
thank you again
um for joining us today and and sharing
your experiences and and your knowledge
um
it has been a pleasure
um with that i want to thank everybody
who joined us today
and uh it's been a delight and uh we
wish all of you a great rest of your day
thanks for joining us
thank you
you